ok today we're going to look at
respiration
now what respiration means is it
basically means releasing energy from
glucose so we need respiration to occur
in order to release energy now a really
common mistake is lots of people think
respiration is the same as breathing's
that is not the case respiration is not
breathing breathing is how we get oxygen
into our body in the first place
respiration is releasing energy from
glucose they're very different processes
also breathing occurs in the lungs
whereas respiration occurs in every cell
so they have completely different
processes please do not get them
confused so first of all we're going to
have a look at this thing called aerobic
respiration respiration so what aerobic
respiration is when we see aerobic it
just means with oxygen now this one is
much more efficient than the other one
we're going to look at in a minute now
in aerobic respiration it occurs in the
part of the cells called the
mitochondria so this is the site of
aerobic respiration so remember it's a
cellular process is happening in every
cell not the lungs not just the lungs
even okay so what is our equation for a
robic respiration so we need glucose
first of all in order to get our energy
think about that glucose type of sugar
we need sugar to give us energy we also
need oxygen from the air for aerobic
respiration this is why I think some
people get it confused with breathing
but we need oxygen from the air as well
our waste products are carbon dioxide
and water which we exhale when we
breathe out so where do we get these
from now
glucose we get this from our diet so we
eat this oxygen comes from the air so
these two things we need in order to
respire if we did not get either of
these things we cannot make any energy
and therefore we die so let's see what
the symbol equation is this for for this
particular equation so glucose is
c6h12o6 oxygen should hopefully no it's
just Oh two carbon dioxide is co2 and
water is just h2o now to balance this
it's really really nice and easy because
we just need a six a six and a six six
six six maybe that's a good way of
remembering it if anyone likes the rock
and roll music six six six so the nice
thing about the respiration equation is
it's the absolute opposite of the
photosynthesis equation so if you were
to switch around the reactants and the
products you would have your
photosynthesis reaction so that will
help you with both of those equations so
the other type of respiration is
anaerobic respiration
now what anaerobic means anaerobic
anaerobic just means without oxygen so
this one here is much less efficient
it's not as good as aerobic respiration
it releases less energy now in animals
in in people this is for activities that
are really kind of fast-acting
activities such as weightlifting or
sprinting these types of activities are
really a where weight lifts are examples
of anaerobic respiration without oxygen
because they happen very very quickly
no we actually again remember
respiration always involves glucose so
even though anaerobic doesn't involve
oxygen it does involve glucose however
we've got completely different products
this time we only have one
product and that is lactic acid
now lactic acid can build up in muscles
and it can cause cramp which is painful
and can actually damage the muscles so
this is anaerobic respiration in animals
however it's not just animals that
undergo anaerobic respiration plants can
as well now in plants anaerobic
respiration again anaerobic means
without oxygen but this time the
equations a bit difficult different
again every single time something all of
these have in common is they always have
glucose as our reactant but this time
our products are ethanol and carbon
dioxide
now ethanol is a type of alcohol and
this process here is actually how
fermentation works in order to produce
alcohol for consumption so again we
start off with glucose anaerobic so we
did not have any oxygen and we full
ethanol and carbon dioxide this in fact
can happen in fungi as well so guys just
to summarize just to summarize
respiration means releasing energy
releasing energy from glucose it does
not mean breathing it happens in every
cell in the body aerobic respiration is
with oxygen anaerobic respiration is
without oxygen here is the equation for
aerobic respiration anaerobic
respiration in animals causes lactic
acid which can cause crafts anaerobic
respiration in plants releases the
products ethanol and carbon dioxide
thanks very much